سنه 2022 شاره فتعل الانتهاء سنه شهدت
انتعاشا كبيرا في مجال السفر والسؤال الذي
يطرحه خبراء السياحه اين تتوجه الامطار في
السنه المقبله على كل حال اذا كنت تبحث عن
مكانا مثالي لمغامرتك المقبله فان موقع
لون لبنات اصدر قائمه تولي افضل الوجهات
السياحيه حول العالم لعام 20-23 القائمه
اخذت شكلا جديدا هذه السنه حيث تم تقسيم
الوجوهات الثلاثين التي تم اختيارها الى
خمس فئات هي الطعام والتعلم والمغامرات
والاسترخاء والتواصل
[موسيقى]
طيب طيب
المقبل
اليوم
اكثر من 40 مليار دولار اللي هو السفر
همم يعني مثل همم بيت خشبي وتشتركين مع
اخرين فيفا اللي حاب يرجع الى الطبيعه
اللي حاب يبتعد شويه عن الستره اللي هتكون
اغلى بكثير خصوصا تكاليف الاكل والشرب
والطرعات والتنقل الى اخره فهذه من الحلول
الدكتوره
حتى تطلعي همم الجبل كان مرتفع كثير
كانت تجربه
قطاع السفر 246 مليار دولار انه غير انه
هناك همم المونديال طبعا فهنا العديد من
المشاريع الخاصه والحكوميه في السعوديه
هناك العديد من المشاريع السياحيه التي
تشجع السياحه ايضا عوده السياحه المعتمرين
والحجاج وايضا من المتوقع انه 286 مليار
دولار بعد تقريبا ست سنوات فالمنطقه ما
شاء الله تشهد انتعاش كبيره في السياحه